hallo ihr lieben das kind ihr von mein
rezept videos so starte ich sie immer
heute geht es aber um was anderes ich
stehe hier aber schon richtig denn das
hier ist meine küche im haus meiner
eltern ich habe zugegeben damals den
segen dass ich im haus meiner eltern
eine eigene kleine wohnung habe
allerdings ist die küche sehr alte küche
ist immer auf der anderen seite und das
ist die 20 jahre alte küche meiner
eltern alles schon ein bisschen alt und
hier und da geht etwas kaputt und heute
zeige ich euch die küche legt denn heute
zeige ich euch nur schöne sachen denn
wir zeigen euch heute haben wir es
nämlich hinter der kamera wird zeigen
euch heute das küchenstudio in dem wir
unsere küche plant und dann seht ihr
schon mal wie unsere küche aussehen wird
jetzt packe ich meine sachen meine
tasche mein autoschlüssel und ich habe
auch noch leckere brownies gemacht die
mich auch mit und jetzt gehen wir
zusammen schließt gleich so ihr lieben
liefern jetzt nach bochum zu maria
küchen ich erzähle euch jetzt unterwegs
warum das meine wahl küchenstudio
geworden ist und zwar hansa und ich wir
haben ja die hochzeitsfeier bald aber
die wohnung in bochum
die haben wir schon vor vier monaten
angemietet
das heißt ich suche seit ungefähr vier
monaten schon nach einem passenden
küchenstudio ich war auch in großen
möbelhäusern natürlich weil ich jetzt
als erstes in großen möbelhäusern und
mir ist einfach aufgefallen die preise
sind da gar nicht so günstig wie man
immer denkt nächste mainz küchenstudio
und war eher küchen war gerade auf dem
weg als hansa und ich bei schwinger man
kaffee trinken wollten
da war es halt auf dem weg und haben
maria kirch neueröffnung weise was durch
spontane wir sind wir gehen jetzt daran
hohen angebot für exakt die gleiche
küche die ich im möbelhaus hat planen
lassen und siehe da es war tatsächlich
die gleiche leistung die wir tatsächlich
fünfziger habe mein nachbar der waldemar
und genau
und dann haben wir dann irgendein
offenbart
markus war der marcus izmir zu wir sind
youtuber und deine küche mit total
präsent sein hass nicht los mit uns auch
zu filmen und genau deswegen fahren wir
jetzt dahin und filmen und ihr macht
euch gleich ein bisschen einen eigenen
eindruck von ihnen
[Musik]
da machen wir mal gemeinsam reingehen
kommt mit
jetzt stehe ich hier bei varia küchen
neben mir der markus markus ich habe
gerade schon auf dem hinweg ein bisschen
von dmc dass wir gemeinsam die küche
geplant habe jetzt jedoch gerne selber
mal zwei sätze über dich ja ich bin der
markus- und ja wir haben jetzt hier seit
anfang des jahres neue studio aufgemacht
wir haben schon seit 45 jahren knapp und
im studio und haben mein vater mein
bruder ich und mitarbeiter noch also
familienbetrieb quasi ja und jetzt sind
wir im hoch um neue einer hattinger
straße und ja dann haben sie uns auch
kennengelernt und genau irgendwie passte
weil die chemie ob die chemie passt so
gefordert wie kommen wir hier ein ganz
unvoreingenommen wir waren vorher das
habe ich schon erzählt in großen
möbelhäusern sind dann ganz spontan
herein auf dem weg zu schwiegermama und
danach haben wir die erzählt markus sind
eigentlich youtube und die kirche wird
präsent sein in genau im internet und
jetzt sind wir hier und ich find's ganz
cool dass das duo auch bereit bist mein
zu schauen so ein bisschen erklären auf
was man achten sollte beim küchenkauf
und hier so ein bisschen die highlights
zeigt jetzt sind wir hier schon in
deiner highlight küche oder das alles so
die haupt angeschlossen der küche
funktioniert auch alles machen braucht
man schon so kopf fahren schneider
schule und ja da dieser nicht alles drin
was so geht momentan okay dann sag uns
doch mal so die zweite heirat sich in
der küche sind also fangen wir
eigentlich machen die haube ist momentan
schon ja schon hingucken wer hier
reinkommt hast ein riesending ist sie
gibt es verschiedene varianten das ist
jetzt so die fast die größte auch
smartphone steuerung mit led-beleuchtung
farbe steuert das hier gerade recht über
bluetooth hoch und runterfahren und bei
einer normalen deckenhöhe fährt wie auch
komplett bis zu diesen platz runter aber
weil wir so einen laden jahr mussten wir
die sache etwas verlängern dann bleibt
halt auf einer gewissen höhe steht aber
noch mal je nachdem kann man sie sogar
auch in eine decke ein lassen ja eine
kunde etwas neues baut kann man auch um
aussparungen direkte mache und das dem
komplett versehen dass man wirklich das
siehst du nur noch so ein lichtband
unter der decke und du hast leuchtkörper
und meine sie brauchst erstes tor unter
und die hat jetzt noch eine besonderheit
die macht auch noch musik und das auch
beim kochen und backen irgendwie
gebraucht die musik eine bessere laune
auch gerade haben sie sich ein neues
iphone ist wie gesagt kommt wir machen
da mal eine haube mit sound weil jeder
hat eigentlich so ein lautsprecher zu
hause nach alexa oder was irgendwo muss
ich raus kommt in dem zuge kommen in der
küche machen wir alles in einem recht
gute qualität
also wird es kochen richtig zum erlebnis
wenn ihr auch musik beim kochen und
backen also ich bin persönlich so dann
ist es also es ist ein echt coole idee
[Musik]
und das ist mir sofort aufgefallen als
jetzt erst einmal hier war was ist das
für ein wahnsinns kochfeld erklärt mal
sind im endeffekt drei teile also wir
haben hier wie sehr wir heute auch
kupfer anschauen dann mit meinem kunden
alles zeigen kann was es erlebt weil wir
jetzt hier
das ist so eine seiner edelstahl
grillplatte wo die details und ich kann
sofort mein steak drauf braten gemüse
pentax im endeffekt alles ist wie eine
fahne zu bedienen aber halt deutlich
deutlich größer wie haben sie das denn
der dreier kommen einfach nur
nebeneinander in einem stein eingelassen
dann haben wir ein normales 60er
induktionsfeld genau das kennt man ja
insofern genau das hatten normales
kochfeld endeffekt und hier immer noch
mal eine andere stelle kommen gleich zu
viele wissen ja gar nicht was induktion
mob ist oder wo die vorteile liegen und
wir haben ein bisschen wasser im topf
gemeint also der hauptvorteil option ist
es deutlich deutlich schneller genau
also 30 anlagen fällt genau braucht weil
sie nicht zehn minuten je nachdem wie
viel wie viel wasser auch drin ist
induktion schritt ist ja vier fünfmal so
schnell je nachdem was für ein
hersteller man da auch hat wir haben ein
bisschen was von einem top verein
gemacht da sieht man mal wie schnell das
überhaupt kommt wenn man manchmal nudeln
kochen aber auch meine ordentlich wasser
am großen tag erwartet man schon mal
ewig bei einem zelt und so geht's
wirklich deutlich schneller
[Musik]
und induktion hat immer so ein bisschen
das so ein bisschen also je nach top
qualität auch je mehr eisenanteil dran
ist desto leiser ist ok
weniger eisenanteil desto lauter ist und
ob und das hauptmerkmal ist läuft über
magnetismus jetzt einmal den sprudel
darunter nicht wie bei dem ceranfeld zum
strahl heizkörper der das glas erhitzt
hier wird der topf direkt erhitzt und da
sieht man es jetzt schon relativ schnell
in ihre minuten lang noch nicht wahr
es ist nicht viel drin abermals zum
vorführen
es ist ein recht schnell ja normal ist
ceranfeld geht halt glühend heiß 350
grad irgendwo oberflächentemperatur da
kann ich noch kein antrag machen dann
ist ihren weg bei induktion wird der
topf direkt erhitzt und da kann ja drauf
hast es ist warm fast vor man also es
ist schon ein wagnis nicht aber man hat
sich jetzt nicht verletzt und das wasser
hat gekocht deshalb nur die restwärme
die der topf basiert also zusätzlich
nochmal die sicherheit da wenn man mal
kleinkind genau das und wenn ich jetzt
an schalten würde es passiert gar nichts
der top fuß drauf also der kontakt mit
den topstars passiert da gar nichts und
da ist noch eine sauberere geschichte
weil dadurch dass die flächen nicht so
heiß wird kann wasser oder sahne
irgendwie milch überkocht nicht ins glas
ein brennender ungenau wenn ich fliege
ja ja ich kenne das von früher ist so
ärgerlich und das ist jetzt mein
highlight genau das musste jetzt mal in
sachen erklären ich war schon mal den
worten ich möchte die aktions stelle oft
aber passend für den wok kennt man auch
viele restaurants höchst auch passt halt
direkt am objekt komplette fläche wird
bereits fast bis hier oben hin also ich
hab wirklich in der komplette
hitzeentwicklung in der ganzen fahne und
muss in einem workout nicht nur
chinesisch oder asiatisch machen rund um
den globus aber ich mache es gerne mit
dem bock aber ich habe so ein schönes
teil nicht zu hause
ich habe auch noch mal zum zeigen dass
sowas auch gibt dass diese decke chor
muss ich gleich dass das auch privat
eine großküche sieht man das manchmal
vapiano oder im jahr genau das hat ja
nicht wo da steht man vor und kann man
halt auch selber für zuhause haben
[Musik]
bei uns in der türkei ist es ja heute
noch so dass die hausfrauen gerne mit
einem gasherd kochen und ich glaube es
gibt auch feine unterschiede zwischen
gasherd und induktion
ich persönlich habe mich aber dennoch
für induktion entschieden weil ich weiss
es ihr zu hause auch mehrheitlich
induktionsherde habt aber trotzdem finde
ich es auch mal interessant sich das
noch mal anzusehen
[Musik]
so und jetzt sind wir hier in meiner
heimat küche zugegebenermaßen irgendwie
das komplette gegenteil weil ich mag mir
diese hellen farben und ich hätte auch
gerne für meine küche genommen ist aber
da hast du mir auch schon von vornherein
abgeraten denn weiß fleck hat in den
videos und dann habt ihr augenschmerzen
und das macht er keinen sinn
und jetzt wäre vielleicht noch mal ganz
interessant was sollte man so von
vornherein mitbringen wenn man reinkommt
was für informationen sollte man habe
bevor man sich von dir beraten lässt
grundsätzlich wenn man jetzt schon eine
wohnung gefunden sagt okay ich hab mir
so ein haus eine wohnung einfach mal so
grobe marx damit bringen damit wir
ungefähr wissen okay ihr habt ihr stehen
und den raum muss er sich perfekt
ausgerissen sein das reicht so groben
zeitplan halten drückt ihn mal daumen
fenster tür wo die anschlüsse ungefähr
sind wasser und strom
und dann können wir schon mal loslegen
und planen sowie ihr hattet ihr auch
noch dann ist gibt es dabei dann kann
man halt schon mal irgendwo hab meine
grundbasis dass wir auch eine grobe
vorstellung
und was ganz gut ist fotos oder ein
kleines video oder so von dem raum dann
haben wir noch mal ein ganz gutes bild
manchmal sehen die hat noch sache wohl
gesagt vielleicht gedacht da ist doch
nur eine heizung oder so und dann haben
wir sofort die info darüber genau das
hatten wir auch wir haben natürlich mein
ziel eines machtverzichts und ford das
ist ja das wäre noch ganz gut zweiter
punkt wie viele personen im haushalt
leben oder wie viel halt zusammen oft
kochen damit wir ungefähr wissen okay
was den stauraum wie groß muss der
kühlschrank seinem gefrierschrank damit
wir ein paar infos haben so über die die
räumlichkeiten was gebraucht wird ja
ansonsten der dritte punkt einig so der
mit wichtigste mitte man muss sich halt
immer irgendwo so grob schon mal ein
budget festlegen muss sich auf den euro
genau sein aber man sagt okay ich hab
jetzt 5000 euro 2.000 euro 10.000 euro
was kriege ich dafür wie versuchen halt
auch mal von kunden immer das beste
rauszuholen okay du hast du das und das
budget in denen der stattküche gucken
was die geräte übernehmen
aber so dass man perfekte mix nur es ist
für uns halt immer wichtiger für schon
eine grobe richtung müssen als wenn man
sich alles toll aussucht und am ende ist
dann preis habe ich jetzt nicht
mitgerechnet
aber das wäre schon
gut so lange als punktgenau perfekt also
das sind die drei punkte die einfach mal
für euch mitnehmen müsst bevor ihr hier
reinkommt oder generell in der küche
planen lässt und ich denke wir schauen
uns jetzt mal unsere küche an richtig da
freue ich mich schon richtig drauf und
dann sehen sie auch zum ersten mal in
der 3d ansicht genau und da gehen wir
hin
[Musik]
bevor es jetzt an die 3d planung geht
müssen wir uns im klaren darüber sein
welche freunden und welche
arbeitsförderung erstmal genau schauen
wir uns mal die auswahl an
wir haben also ein paar musste schon
nach vorbereitet hingelegt weil wir ihn
auf jeden fall der matte front keine
glänzten neben einer gegenreaktion
spiegelungen wirklich lecker ist genau
der unterschied weil es gibt halt grau
grau grau und weiß und wird deshalb
browser oder trend farbe dunkelgrau
etwas hätte das kommt dann hat man noch
mal schönen kontrast wie sich die farben
unterscheiden das wird so ganz anders
weiß das feld im endeffekt schon mal
raus aufs feld raus
in der gattung erklärt einfach wegen das
flackern kann man das schon mal und dann
gibt es im endeffekt zu dreitürer soll
eine neutrale farbe seien keine holz
oder emi so oder so eine maserung oder
sowas
lieber etwas schlichtes gibt es in
seinen grau wer also ein paar grau
steingrau jeder kennt das andere ein
dunkles schiefergrau ich finde ich schön
kann aber auch zu dunkel sein kann auf
dauer zu dunkel sein grab genau da finde
ich halt haben wir dazu wenig kontrast
ist es fast weiß je nach licht auch
wieder ist schon sehr hell
aber wenn wir jetzt kein weiß daneben
hat man sagen das ist weist und damit
eigentlich gesagt würde ich sagen der
die farbe genanntes steingrau also das
wäre jetzt quasi das wäre doch konnten
und ich finde die auch sehr schöne
dadurch dass es auch so schöner ist es
halt doch nicht da sich die japaner
schichtung auch er pflegeleicht da
kannst du glasreiniger daran gehen ist
supereinfach sauber und passt auch ganz
gut zu eurer wandfliesen mitgebracht die
ich mitgebracht die ist von fliesen
zelle habe ich euch im blog da mal
mitgenommen und zwar das ist einmal die
diese für die rückwand und außerdem auch
noch auf dem boden also die wird sich
noch mal spiegeln im boden wird es auch
nochmal vorhanden sein und da passt eben
die front super und jetzt ist die frage
welche arbeitsweise welche arbeitsfläche
nehmen wieder drauf das ist auch nicht
zu grau in grau wer immer gesagt wir
nehmen schon irgendwas bildschön
flächenbündige um einlassen können so
was geht hat auch nur bei stein keramik
quarzstein also in der normalen
kunststoff arbeitsplatte geht's die
menschen verlieren aber generell nicht
weil ist eine spanplatte und wenn ich
das versiegeln will das geht auf dauer
nicht ich habe gesagt in entscheidungs
für keramik wir haben auch mal so ein
paar musste jetzt wieder jeden gesagt
gut zu einer hellgrauen front würde ich
schon etwas dunkleres nehmen als primas
irgendwo also man zum beispiel was
hellwig hält das ist alles so ton in ton
bei uns genau das finde ich schon was in
dir ist hier ist halt so ein bisschen
gold glitzer somit drin
kann man machen geschmackssache
dies hat sehr krass gemasert das war so
ein paar welche schuld zu finden zu
dieser kombination ist die das halt so
nennt er sich ist jetzt eine keramik
platte schnittfest kratzfest kannst du
heißen topf heißes backblech darauf
stellen nicht kaputt ein untersetzter
hexe also das messer wird eigentlich
auch solltest du nicht nein weil ich
brauche keinen ich brauche quasi gar
keinen
schneidebretter eigentlich hat nicht
rolf schneider wenn man entspannt ich
mir das auch gleich oder warst einfach
aufstellen und lukas halt sofort drauf
arbeiten bestimmt sauber pflegeleicht
ist momentan nicht so das härteste oder
beste material für die küche ja okay
dann ist das die perfekte da finde diese
promi schon die kombination jetzt
schreibt eben jedoch gerne in die
kommentare wie findet ihr die
kombination vielleicht haben so kannst
du auch gleich noch mal ein bisschen
näher heran kommt
also mir gefällt so ganz gut und ich
freue mich jetzt als üblich ich freue
mich auf die 360 grad
diese 3d ansicht der küche also vorüber
doch noch kippen
[Musik]
dazu natürlich kommt der haben sie dazu
dann ist es ja unsere erste gemeinsame
wohnung mit der ersten gemeinsamen küche
und du hast auch ein bisschen
mitspracherecht ein bisschen schon
das ist so ein bisschen das noch mal ein
bisschen heißt genau zu den schränken
genau wie habe jetzt mal so ja
eigentlich ein plan soweit fertig das
fahrrad noch vergessen wir haben keinen
griff ausgerufen weil wenn der griff
muss küche auch darum gesagt ihr neben
den griff kriegt man einfach ein
bisschen zeitloser ist und es ist auch
pflegeleicht wo das quasi nur glatte
freundin hast keinen eingriff drumherum
putzen genau an um sie doch ganz schick
aus und werden jetzt in die küche
ihr habt der küche und wohnzimmer alles
in einem
dadurch dass er als kind habe ich viel
kriegt man im raum stehen und dann passt
natürlich ein esstisch persönlichkeiten
deswegen haben wir so eine schöne
holzdecke mit eingebracht das war ja
mehr alles in grau mit der grauen fliese
mit dunkel also verschiedene grautöne
geräte sind ja irgendwas schwarz aber so
ein bisschen holz haben gesagt lockert
das ganze das ein bisschen auf und es
müssen wir haben uns sicher auch schick
aus wenn er da mal was besonderes
es wäre halt noch ein bisschen
freundlicher alles ist neu aufbauen wenn
dann jetzt hier am anfang großen
kühlschrank kleines eisfach aber da
vielleicht ein riesencoup schon damit
ihr möglich viele sachen auch kühl
lagern könnte und so weiter backofen
mikrowelle die kombi hoch gebaut
natürlich bisschen schöner auch vom film
dass du nicht halten wenn ihr gerade mal
gucken rausholen so schön fühlen können
ansonsten haben wir jetzt bei euch alles
mit schuppen ausgestattet weil es
einfach das ist praktisch und
übersichtlich csu daraus hat man
bestellt hat meine töpfe meine
tupperdosen hier habt wahrscheinlich
auch sehr dass man das alles im
überblick hat
[Musik]
und dann kommen wir oben hängen schenkel
gesagt wir machen jetzt nicht alles zu
sondern lockern das ein bisschen auf mit
zwei regal rom ist ein deko kochbücher
halt vielleicht ein eigenes kochbuch
dahinter ja das ist auf jeden fall im
planungen und dann findet seinen
ehrentag genommen haben auch so ein
bisschen agent überläuft damit
reingepackt so okay man hat auch abends
wenn er dann im wohnzimmer sitzt und
bisschen licht doch habt in der küche
das man halt nicht die große haupt
beleuchtung ab sondern ein bisschen
dieses an der unterricht haben wir auch
zusätzlich unter der arbeitsplatte
es soll eine kleine sonne licht schiene
in diesem griffmulden profil dass man
halt auch so ein kleines ambiente nicht
alles klar ist dass wegen der
schwebenden hatte wirken ist filigraner
nochmal und einfach es macht auch schon
echt schönes licht oder sondern dann
abends fuchs fernsehers und du hast hat
noch ein bisschen licht an dass nicht
alle stücke man muss halt nochmal
erwähnen unsere küche ist quasi mit dem
wohnzimmer 1 also wenn wir abends auf
der couch sitzen und netflix gucken dann
in der küche hat bildet immer die küche
und das werden wir machen nicht immer
aber dass genau also so ist es dann
manchmal sitzt quasi und guckt immer
drauf ein bisschen sind die lichter halt
so schön das genau dazu setzt das locker
zahlt oder ganz aus sondern nur so
juhnke küche da stehen dass die seite
auf wie gesagt schubladen wieder in der
mitte den kopf fällt und da haben wir
jetzt von bärbel sondern lüfter genommen
das heißt induktionsfeld mit der
abzugshaube integriert damit ihr nicht
einfach wieder irgendwo im raum hängt
stößt sich den raum genau gestört und
filmt aber von der technik untersagen
ist das vom werbe das kochfeld auch echt
einsamen funktioniert perfekt ich habe
selber zu hosen und besucher heißt das
dass wir endlich
[Musik]
ansonsten kann man sich fast alles sehr
gut steckdosen haben wir noch gesagt
machen wir vorne weil bei dem kochfeld
haben wir keine schublade weil da der
lifter sitzt ja komfortabel steckdosen
in die blender rein emotional hier
angucken kann man nix wird nix ja was
brauchst sofort hast du eine steckdose
parat und rost nicht den puck in
verlängerungskabel oder so habe das
jetzt so ja ja der steckdose schon
wichtig in der küche deswegen auch nicht
zu wenig steckdosen planen beim neubau
oder so immer berechtigt und endlich
umsonst oder unsere küche perfekt freuen
wir uns schon richtig drauf und ich
freue mich und wir werden dann nochmal
auf die einzelnen schupp leben eingehen
wenn die küche wirklich steht und dann
werde ich euch noch mal genau sagen
warum das so wichtig ist und die
funktionalität also werden wir euch dann
auch alles erklären und natürlich ein
ordnungssystem was dann reinkommt da
freue ich mich auch schon darauf
[Musik]
so das war unsere kleine tour durch
maria küchen danke auch noch mal dass
wir hier filmen durften ist ja auch
nicht selbstverständlich sind ja echt
spaß gemacht also ich würde jetzt gleich
monate macchiato nehmen
super und dann können wir uns noch die
brownies die ich gemacht habe und falls
ihr fragen habt auch gerne an dich
gewöhnt auch e-mails schreiben info at
waren alles bochum oder auch über
instagram facebook bleibe aber wenn ihr
fragen habt schreiben die er perfekt
vielen dank dafür und dann wünsche ich
euch jetzt noch einen schönen tag und
wir sehen uns dann im nächsten video
chats
[Musik]
hamza com
natürlich ohne dich markus jetzt kannst
du beim preis machen gekommen irgendwas
muss doch gehen oder haben sie ganz
ehrlich hand aufs herz